if we want to stay there for a second
and let's just highlight a little bit
more deeper operation Car Wash okay I'll
tell you what I found and then you tell
me if this is correct or if you want to
add anything to it okay so operation Car
Wash uh uh biggest corruption and
history of Brazil ever uh leave the
world yeah I mean I've heard world I've
heard obviously Brazil but it's it's
political biggest corruption you read
about uh then the people know what's
happening the some of the people that
voted for Lula they say everybody steals
from us but we like this guy you know at
least this guy gives us some of the
money that he's also stealing he gives
it to us as well that's what I've heard
some people say now that may be right or
wrong uh when this took place there was
this uh perfect place where they were
building this ambitious energy project
itabori in Brazil estimated to create
200 000 jobs it was 45 kilometers square
kilometers
and during this time when they're going
through this project it caused Lula to
uh go to jail for 12 years which she
only did 580 days give or take at this
federal police headquarters and city of
curitibia if I'm not mistaken his
successor Dilma was impeached uh then
her successor Michelle was charged for
corruption the former CEO of odebrecht
Marcelo de brecht went to jail for 19
years the case showed that the company
paid 788 million dollars in bribes in
connection with more than a hundred
projects in 12 different countries from
2001 to 2006. elike Batista which at one
point was the richest man
with a net worth of 35 billion dollars
in 2012 the next year his net worth goes
from 35 billion to 200 million dollars
the following year according to
Bloomberg in 2014 his net worth is minus
one billion dollars he went to jail for
30 years in 2016 11 projects were
stalled in Brazil alone due to this
corruption 17 projects were stalled in
seven other countries Cuba Guatemala
Honduras Dominican Republic Colombia
Peru Venezuela Argentina one irrigation
project in Peru where three former
presidents were accused of taking money
from obrecht and eventually this
operation Car Wash Scandal cost
Brazilians 500 000 jobs now here's the
thing if something like this happens and
Lula's name is tied to it when he left
you see the numbers his popularity was
eighty percent ninety percent you read
stats like that how does a person like
this come back and is able to run and
win because you know in America they'll
say well look at Biden's corruption look
what they've done Biden's never done
time in jail we don't have presidents
that have done jail time in U.S and come
back and get they get elected some
people want to have many of our
presidents go to jail some people say
that guy belongs in jail this guy
belongs in jail but this guy actually
went to jail and he got caught stealing
money and bribery and he wins how does
that happen in a country like Brazil
that's a very good question Patrick and
I think we need to go to the media to
answer that like a lot of similarities
what uh what's going on in Brazil that
what happened two years ago in United
States so the narrative they have is
that bolsonaro just like Trump is a huge
threat to democracy he's a fascist he's
gonna uh took power and never leave and
all that so with this narrative the
media goes against bolsonaro in every
detail like with very fake news
narratives and uh and by the same way
but at the same time uh the Supreme
Court releases Lula for finds that the
judge responsible for his first
condemnation he was convicted he was
considered guilty guilt but in the first
decision Sergio Moro that the judge
behind the the car wash operation he's
fine like uh uh he he's uh suspicious
his he has political interests so uh
they released Lula and after many years
they kind of find a problem with the ZIP
code oh Lula was not supposed to be
judged by the car wash operation the
legal system in kurichiba he was
supposed to be judged in Brasilia and
they find it uh four or five years later
and then they considered Lula able to
run again which was not possible by law
in Brazil so to understand and to answer
uh what what's going on in Brazil and to
answer your question it's very important
to understand that the whole system and
I mean the Supreme Court the the
Congress and the media the 90 of the
media they were trying to help Lula go
back to Power because they want
bolsonaro out of it they want to get rid
of bolsonaro that's the first goal so
they try many different names in the
center left Paulo mentioned that there's
kind of a a fight among the left they
try many names in the center left no one
worked because they they don't have the
popularity and Lula still has some
especially in the the poor parts of
Brazil so they try many names and then
they came with Lula with this kind of
rigged decisions uh to to get rid of
bolsonaro that's what happened and and
you you ask if we hold mostly the same
opinions uh and when we do I think
that's the area we differ a little bit
uh because I agree with 99 of what he's
had so what happens that establishment
noticed after bolsonaro got elected they
were so surprised and they were like
what's going on what what what the hell
is going on here the Russia collusion
was not a thing in Brazil but WhatsApp
uh and robots and the same the same
excuses to why the sky which they
portrayed as the Devil Himself how this
guy got elect it so they were like okay
who can beat this guy
no one
so the like he mentioned the center guys
they were like dull politically no big
names
and they were okay uh I think we need to
re-establish uh Lula's reputation
so he was a and I agree with him he was
um
uh a union between
the media the mainstream media big role
in that big role they shifted 180
degrees so you've got the same news
anchors like Maine like our uh CBS
Evening News okay global global yeah
Global you got William Bonner the same
guy that was like Lula was convicted of
corruption to two years later he was
like oh Lula you've been acquitted in
all courts it's like no you you have not
so what happened is that yes so the
media the Supreme Court with the Justice
appointed by Lula and the elites I'm
talking about financial markets as well
the Academia everyone the whole
establishment they all got together and
said we gotta we gotta support do that
and that's how they rebranded and
re-established this reputation but that
being said that was only possible in my
humble opinion because operation car
wash
became a power grab and in the middle in
the middle of it okay but they lost
their ways so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]